[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think it's absolutely
insane that Kamala is actually
going to be in one of
the biggest Marvel games
that we've done.
BILL ROSEMANN: She's
a very recent addition
to the Marvel universe.
She was only invented--
gosh, about six years ago.
But even though she's very
new, she's very classic.
SANA AMANAT: She is a young
hero from Jersey City,
and she has something called
polymorph powers, which means
she can contort her
body in different ways,
and she can get really
big, and really small.
We spent countless
hours on the story,
on the choice of character,
how we would portray her.
I loved working
with Shaun Escayg
and the rest of the creative
team at Crystal Dynamics.
To sit down with Shaun and
talk about the characters,
and how he saw them.
To stay true to her, we spent
a lot of time in the comics,
and then also tapping
into our version of her.
The biggest difference between
our game and the Kamala people
have met in the comics, she
gains her powers on A day.
SANA AMANAT: She is essentially
just a little fan girl, right?
She's a nerd.
She loves the Marvel universe.
She lives in the
Marvel universe.
Her fan fiction
comic is selected
for the Avengers celebrations.
HANNAH MCLEOD: The
Avengers are unveiling
this experimental technology,
and something pretty crazy
happens with it.
SHAUN ESCAYG: She's
exposed to Terrigen gas,
and is now labeled what
is called an Inhuman.
HANNAH MCLEOD: She's
got Super Powers
that she doesn't know
what to do is in a world
that hates Super Heroes.
BILL ROSEMANN: She
suspects that the Avengers
were set up in A Day.
The role that Kamala
plays is a unifier.
She's really someone
who is going to bring
the Avengers back together.
Casting Kamala was
a difficult process.
We spent a lot of time
looking for Sandra,
and she did an impeccable
job bringing her life.
Oh, my god.
When I found out I was going to
play the role of Kamala Khan,
I was like, are you kidding?
I'm an Avenger?
She's a lot like the
character in many ways.
So there's instant
believability.
SANDRA SAAD: She is a first
generation American, like me.
She's a young woman
of color who has
trouble fitting in, like I do.
And I feel like she has all
these personal struggles
that everyone can relate to.
In the cast of
seasoned actors,
she is the new one in some
sense that that forced structure
between the seasoned
actors and the new actor
is sort of like
the actual Kamala
Khan relationship to her
world, and to her environment.
We wanted to really
focus on her gameplay,
and her style of
moves reflecting
her development as a character.
So you might notice that there's
at least one or two attacks
that she's sort of,
like, made her own
from the other
Avengers, and sort
of integrated into our moveset.
One of the most iconic
things about Kamala
is her ability to embiggen,
and we actually realized this
in a bunch of different ways.
She's able to, like,
lengthen her attacks,
she's able to avoid
attacks while she sort
of mini-embiggens.
And then we also have
the ultra-embiggen state
where she gets giant sized.
And at this point, she's
able to send enemies flying.
We actually built an
entirely new reaction
set for the enemies to,
like, really deliver on
the feel of being,
you know, three times,
four times the
size of the enemies
you're sort of kicking around.
SANDRA SAAD: Putting
together a movement
style for Kamala is just all
in the imagination, I feel.
Because at the end
of the day, it's
you who's standing there
in this mocap space,
imagining that your
arm, Sandra's arm,
is stretching out to the end
of the room to grab somebody.
It's just fun.
I hope the fans notice
those little details,
and I hope the fans see how
hard every single person worked.
And I hope the fans love
the story as much as I do.
When it comes to a new
perspective on the Avengers,
seeing them from a
fan girl, of someone
who has always wanted to meet
them, has wanted to be one--
we feel like players can
really connect with that.
SANA AMANAT: Marvel
has considered her
an important enough
character to be
on the League of the Avengers.
SHAUN ESCAYG: She's
got Super Hero powers
unlike any other Avenger.
She's not laying
down for no one,
and I think those qualities,
they cross boundaries.
People can relate to it.
She's rebellious.
They want to be her.
I want to be her.
The fact that she is the entry
point character in this game
makes so much sense because
she really is the everyman.
Like, people from all
backgrounds and experiences
can relate to her,
and have related
to her since her inception.
So it makes perfect
sense for her
to be bringing you
into the "Marvel
Avengers" game experience.